>> ♪ ♪
>> Bill: PFIZER ANNOUNCED PLANS
TO SUBMIT ITS VACCINE TO THE FDA
TODAY FOR EMERGENCY APPROVAL.
THAT’S LIGHTNING SPEED AND
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI KNOWS THAT
MOST.
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Bill: I WILL START WITH THE
VACCINE AND ACCENTUATE THE
POSITIVE.
YESTERDAY YOU SAID HELP IS ON
THE WAY.
YOU HAVE BEEN IN THIS JOB SINCE
1984.
DID YOU EVER THINK THE
PRODUCTION AND DEVELOPMENT OF
THIS COULD BE SO QUICK?
>> NO, IN FACT IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN UNIMAGINABLE AT THE TIME I
TOOK THE POSITION AS DIRECTOR OF
THIS INSTITUTE.
VACCINES FROM THE TIME YOU
IDENTIFIED THE PARTICULAR
PATHOGEN, GENERALLY A VIRUS, TO
THE TIME YOU GOT IT APPROVED AND
READY TO PUT INTO PEOPLE WOULD
BE MEASURED IN SEVERAL YEARS.
THE TECHNOLOGY THAT HAS BEEN
DEVELOPED OVER THE PAST COUPLE
OF DECADES TO ALLOW YOU TO GO
JUST GETTING THE JEANETTEGENETIC
SEQUENCE OF THE VIRUS AND
STICKING IT IN A VACCINE
PLATFORM, TO GET IT INTO PEOPLE
IN PHASE-1, LITERALLY WITHIN
A FEW MONTHS, AND THEN TO GET
INTO A PHASE-3 A COUPLE OF
MONTHS LATER.
AND TO HAVE ENOUGH DATA TO SHOW
IT’S EFFICACIOUS AND SAFE IS
UNIMAGINABLE.
IT’S A TESTIMONY TO THE ADVANCES
IN BIO-MEDICAL RESEARCH AND
TECHNOLOGY AND THE ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF RESOURCES PUT IN
OPERATION WARP SPEED TO MAKE
THIS POSSIBLE WITH THIS VACCINE
AND OTHER CANDIDATES IN THE
PIPELINE.
>> Bill: TO THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND ALL OF THOSE
INVOLVED IN OPERATION WARP SPEED
BRAVO FOR THE SPEED BY WHICH YOU
MOVED.
THE MEASLES VACCINE IS 98%
EFFECTIVE.
YOU HAVE 2 VACCINES ON THE TABLE
THAT ARE 95% EFFECTIVE.
YOU NIGHT HAVE 4.
IS COVID 19 EASIER TO MAP OR THE
TECHNOLOGY IS MORE ADVANCED?
>> THE TECHNOLOGY IS THE THING
THAT DID IT AND ALSO THEINATURE
OF THE VIRUS.
SOME BASIC RESEARCH THAT WENT ON
RIGHT HERE AT OUR INSTITUTE
DATING BACK YEARS THAT SHOWED
THAT IF YOU GET THIS MOLECULE
THAT YOU WANT THE BODY TO
RECOGNIZE AND MAKE AN IMMUNE
RESPONSE TO PROTECT YOU AGAINST
THE VIRUS ITSELF.
WHEN YOUR LOOK AT THE VIRUS
UNDER A SENSITIVE MICROSCOPE, IT
HAS THESE SPIKES THAT COME OUT
OF IT.
THAT’S THE REASON THEY CALL IT
A CORONAVIRUS BECAUSE THE SPIKES
LOOK LIKE A CROWN.
THESE SPIKES ARE THE THING WHEN
THE BODY MAKES AN IMMUNE
RESPONSE IT PROTECTS YOU AGAINST
INFECTION OR DISEASE OR SERIOUS
DISEASE.
IT GIVES THE BODY A PROTECTIVE
UMBRELLA.
THE FACT IS YOU HAD TO GET THAT
MOLECULE IN JUST THE RIGHT SHAPE
TO GET THE BOD TOE MAKE AN
OPTIMUM IMMUNE RESPONSE.
THAT PARTICULAR MOLECULE RIGHT
NOW IS USED IN 5 OUT OF THE 6
VACCINES.
>> Bill: THAT’S AMAZING STUFF.
THE GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK SAID
THE ONLY REASON IT’S HAPPENING
IS BECAUSE OF MONEY SUGGESTING
GREED AND PRESIDENT TRUMP’S EGO.
THAT’S DISGUSTING.
WHY WOULD HE SUGGEST THAT AFTER
YOU WHAT JUST LAID OUT?
>> I DON’T KNOW AND I DON’T WANT
TO GET INTO THAT.
BILL.
MY JOB IS TO GET TO THE VACCINES
TO THE PEOPLE.
>> Bill: BUT, DOCTOR, YESTERDAY,
YOU WENT TO THE MICROPHONE AT
THE WHITE HOUSE.
YOU SAID ALL OF THE PEOPLE
AFRAID OF GETTING THIS VACCINE,
IT WAS NOT DONE OUT OF MONEY OR
SPEED, CORRECT?
>> WELL, WHAT HAPPENED IS THAT
THE INVESTMENT THAT WAS MADE IF
OPERATION WARP SPEED WAS A VERY,
VERY SMART AND IMPORTANT
INVESTMENT.
WHAT ONE DOES WITH THAT, YOU
COMBINE THE TECHNOLOGY WHICH
ALLOWED TO YOU DO IT QUICKLY
WITH AN INVESTMENT THAT IN FACT
MAKES THE PROCESS GO MUCH MORE
QUICKLY.
INSTEAD OF WAITING FOR ONE END
POINT TO GO TO THE NEXT AND THE
NEXT, YOU MAKE A RISKY
INVESTMENT.
THE RISK IS NOT TO SAFETY.
THE RISK IS NOT TO SCIENTIFIC
INTEGRITY
INTEGRITY.
THE RISK IS TO MONEY.
IF THE VACCINE WORKS, YOU ARE
MONTHS AHEAD OF THE PROCESS HAD
YOU NOT MADE THAT INVESTMENT.
IF IT DOESN’T WORK, YOU HAVE
LOST A LOT OF MONEY.
>> Bill: YOU GAVE THOSE
COMPANIES A FINANCIAL BACK STOP.
>> WE DID.
>> Bill: ONE QUESTION I GET
ASKED:
WHEN WILL IT BE AVAILABLE?
WHERE DO I SIGN UP.
THE TIMELINE, WITHIN A COUPLE OF
WEEKS EMERGENCY WORKERS, 40
MILLION OF THEM BY THE END OF
DECEMBER.
THOSE WITH UNDERLYING
CONDITIONS.
THEN WE MOVE INTO 2021.
I THINK WE WILL HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION AROUND CHRISTMAS
TIME AGAIN.
IT WILL BE EASTER BEFORE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS HAVE ACCESS
TO IT.
DOES THAT LINE UP WITH YOUR TIME
FRAME AS OF TODAY?
>> IT LINES UP WITH A COUPLE AND
A CORRECTION, BILL.
TALKING ABOUT DOSES BE CAREFUL.
40 MILLION DOSES EQUAL 20
MILLION PEOPLE.
IT’S A PRIME AND A BOOST.
BE CAREFUL ABOUT THAT.
YES, YOU ARE CORRECT.
BY LIKELY THE END OF DECEMBER
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THE FIRST
TIER OF PRIORITY, WHICH HASN’T
YET BEEN DETERMINED.
IT WILL BE DETERMINED BY THE CDC
TOGETHER WITH ADVICE FROM THE
COMMITTEE ON IMUNIZATION
PRACTICES.
WE WILL LEAVE THE FINAL DECISION
TO THEM.
>> Bill: OKAY, NOTED.
WE WILL BE IN THIS POSTURE UNTIL
APRIL.
I THINK THAT’S THE THING TO
EMPHASIZE.
YOU TALK ABOUT SCHOOLS AND
THANKSGIVING.
I KNOW YOU ARE DOING A ZOOM
DINNER WITH YOUR THREE DAUGHTERS
ON THANKSGIVING.
THAT’S THE CHOICE YOU ARE
MAKING.
ALL OF THESE STATES ARE TELLING
PEOPLE YOU CAN’T HAVE MORE THAN
10 PEOPLE IN A ROOM.
I DON’T KNOW HOW AMERICA WILL
TAKE THAT.
I THINK AMERICANS HAVE BEEN
YEARNING FOR A HOLIDAY TO BE
WITH THE PEOPLE THEY LOVE.
I DON’T KNOW IF THEY WILL BE
CHECKING CARS IN THE DRIVEWAY.
YOU ASSESSED YOUR OWN RISK IN
YOUR FAMILY AND YOU WOULD
ENCOURAGE OTHER FAMILIES TO
ASSESS THEIRS?
>> RIGHT.
YOU HAVE THAT RIGHT.
YOU CAN’T MAKE ONE DETERMINATION
FOR EVERYONE.
EVERYONE IS DIFFERENT.
EVERYONE HAS A DIFFERENT FEEL TO
THE TYPE OF RISK THEY WOULD LIKE
TO TAKE.
THE CIRCUMSTANCES WITHIN
FAMILIES ARE DIFFERENT.
THE ONLY THING I CALLED FOR AT
THE PRESS BRIEFING AT THE WHITE
HOUSE YESTERDAY WAS THAT EACH
INDIVIDUAL FAMILY UNIT DO A RISK
BENEFIT DETERMINATION THAT WORKS
FOR YOU.
BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME FAMILIES
THAT YOU WANT TO JUST HAVE THE
FAMILY UNIT THAT LIVES IN THE
HOUSE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF OTHERS THAT
WANT TO HAVE VISITORS COME IN.
YOU SAY, DO WE HAVE A VULNERABLE
OR ELDERLY PERSON?
>> Bill: THAT’S RIGHT.
>> YOU HAVE TO MAKE YOUR
DETERMINATION AS AN INDIVIDUAL
FAMILY UNIT.
I DON’T THINK THIS IS THE RULES
EVERYONE SHOULD DO.
I AM ASKING:
PAUSE FOR A MOMENT AND DO
A DETERMINATION OF THE RISK AND
BENEFIT WITHIN YOUR FAMILY
GROUP.
WHEN YOUR MAKE YOUR DECISION,
THAT’S YOUR DECISION.
NO ONE IS FORCING ANYTHING ON
YOU.
IT’S WORTH CONSIDERING AND THE
REASON I SAY THAT, IS THAT OF
LATE WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT THE
INFECTIONS ARE BEING DRIVEN IN
THIS COUNTRY, A LOT IS INNOCENT,
TYPICAL FAMILY AND FRIENDS
GETTING TOGETHER AT A DINNER OR
A RECEPTION INDOORS WHERE YOU
LET YOUR GUARD DOWN BECAUSE YOU
ARE WITH PEOPLE WITH WHOM YOU
ARE FAMILIAR.
>> Bill: THAT’S A GREAT POINT.
MY FEELING IF THAT’S THE CASE,
WE NEED TO REASSESS OUR POLICIES
WITH RESTAURANTS IN NEW YORK AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
TWO MORE POINTS HERE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, MY IMPRESSION
PUBLICLY IS YOU HAVE A STRAINED
RELATIONSHIP.
MY IMPRESSION PRIVATELYILY CAN
YOU GET ALONG QUITE WELL.
>> WE DO GET ALONG QUITE WELL.
I HAVE GOTTEN ALONG ARE WITH THE
PRESIDENT FROM THE BEGINNING.
OCCASIONALLY THERE IS
A DISAGREEMENT THAT GETS BLOWN
OUT OF PROPORTION.
THEN FROM ARE THINGS THAT ARE
SAID THAT TAKEN IN ONE CONTEXT
OR OTHER.
IN GENERAL, I HAVE A GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE PRESIDENT.
>> Bill: DO YOU BELIEVE WE
SHOULD REJOIN THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION WITHOUT GUARANTEED
REFORMS?
>> IN THIS CASE IT WILL BE AT
VARIANCE WITH THE PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT MADE GOOD POINTS
THAT IT’S A FLAWED ORGANIZATION.
HIS APPROACH IF THAT’S THE CASE,
WE ARE GETTING OUT UNTIL THEY
FIX.
IT I WOULD SAY LET’S TRY TO FIX
IT AS WE MOVE ALONG.
THE WORLD DOES NEED A W.H.O.
WE BOTH AGREE IT’S FLAWED.
BUT HOW YOU ADDRESS THAT FLAW
MIGHT BE DIFFERENT.